CLEARLY -- IF THE PRESIDENT
FAILS, THE WORLD FAILS.
JOINING US NOW, WE HAVE A LOT OF
NEWS TO GET TO.
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES.
MR. CHAIRMAN, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THE FIRST THING I WANT IS YOUR
REACTION TO ROD ROSENSTEIN, A
TWO-PART QUESTION.
DID HE THREATEN TO SUBPOENA THE
EMAILS OF VIEW, OTHER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, YOUR STAFF, AND OTHER
DOCUMENTS?
BECAUSE HE HAD ONE OF HIS TEMPER
TANTRUMS AND GOT ANGRY?
LIVE IN SINGAPORE.
I THINK YOU SHOULD COME AWAY
EVENTUALLY BUT I ENJOY SEEING
YOU THERE.
LISTEN, THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOR -- SINCE LAST AUGUST.
WE SUBPOENAED THEM IN LAST
AUGUST.
WE CONTINUE TO TRY TO GET
DOCUMENTS.
WE CAN'T GET DOCUMENTS.
WE'VE HAD MANY, WHAT I WOULD
SAY, ALTERCATIONS WITH THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL AND HIS
STAFF.
WHAT I THINK IS INAPPROPRIATE --
I AM FINE.
I CAN TAKE THE HEAT.
YOU CAN ATTACK ME ALL YOU WANT.
I'M USED TO IT.
I ENJOY.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO ATTACKING
STAFF AND WHEN THE STAFF FEELS
UNCOMFORTABLE, THAT'S WHEN
YOU'VE GONE TOO FAR.
THE STAFF ARE CITIZENS OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO WORK HARD FOR
THEIR COUNTRY, THEY ARE
PATRIOTS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
COME ON TELEVISION LIKE I DO AND
PLEAD MY CASE.
LOOK, THE STAFF DEFINITELY HAVE
FELT THREATENED.
JUST RECENTLY, THE STAFF WERE
ALL KICKED OUT OF THE ROOM.
WHAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE MOST RIGHT NOW IS
OBSTRUCTION OF A VALID
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
LET ME EXPLAIN TO YOU JUST ONE
POINT, AND I WILL GO BACK TO
YOU, SEAN.
ONE SIMPLE POINTS.
WE'VE BEEN INVESTIGATING THIS
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF.
FISA ABUSE AND OTHER MATTERS.
WE NOW ARE AT THE END.
WE DOCUMENTS.
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED IN THIS
SITUATION.
IN THE LAST WEEKS, THEY HAVE
KICKED OUT THE STAFF.
THE LEAD INVESTIGATORS ON THIS.
NOW THEY HAVE KICKED OUT ALL THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, SO THE ONLY ONES THAT
ARE GOING TO PROVIDE DOCUMENTS
TO THE WHOLE ENTIRE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, ONLY TO
REPUBLICANS.
PAUL RYAN, THE SPEAKER, AND
MYSELF.
THIS IS TOTALLY ACCEPTABLE.
IT'S A CLASSIC CASE OF
OBSTRUCTION OF A CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION.
AT THE PROBLEM WE HAVE HERE IS,
WHO'S GOING TO INVESTIGATE THE
INVESTIGATORS?
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
A STAFFER, CASH PER TOWEL.
IS HE THE ONE OR ONE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO GOT KICKED OUT OF THE
ROOM?
I REALLY WANT TO KNOW, WHEN YOU
THREATEN AND INTIMIDATE, TO USE
THE POWER OF THAT OFFICE, BEING
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL,
ISN'T THAT ITSELF A FORM OF
OBSTRUCTION COMMANDOS THAT
RAISED THE QUESTION OF
IMPEACHING ROD ROSENSTEIN?
>> I WILL TELL YOU, I WOULD
RATHER NOT GET INTO THE NAMES OF
THE STAFF.
IT'S MORE THAN ONE.
FOR THE PARTICULAR INCIDENT,
THERE WERE THREE STAFF IN THE
ROOM BUT THERE'S BEEN MANY
OTHERS THAT HE FELT THREATENED
DIFFERENT LEVELS BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN INTIMIDATED.
OUR MEMBERS HAVE NOT BEEN
INTIMIDATED.
BUT WHAT THEY HAVE DONE NOW, HOW
DO YOU GET TO OBSTRUCTION, HOW
DO YOU GET TO MISLEADING
CONGRESS?
TAKING THIS INFORMATION WE'VE
BEEN LEGALLY ASKING FOR, A LEGAL
SUBPOENA THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ENFORCE, AND YOU MOVE IT
UPSTAIRS AND SAY NO, NO, IT'S
GOING TO BE SUPER TOP-SECRET
INFORMATION THAT WE ARE ONLY
GOING TO GIVE TO THE GANG OF
EIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
PEOPLE IN AMERICA SHOULD BE
ALARMED.
THIS IS A WAY TO HIDE
INFORMATION NOT ONLY FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BUT TO THEIR
CONGRESSMEN.
AND TO THE STAFF THAT WORK FOR
THEM.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU POSSIBLY
GET IT?
IS IT TRUE THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN
BLEW UP AT YOU A NUMBER OF TIMES
AND THAT HE HAS A HORRIBLE
TEMPER?
AND DO YOU VIEW HIS THREAT AS A
FORM OF OBSTRUCTION IN AND OF
ITSELF?
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT QUESTION,
WHETHER OR NOT HE SHOULD REMAIN
IN THAT ROLE.
>> LET ME ANSWER THE FIRST PART.
I HAD TO PSYCHOANALYSIS ON ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU IS THE
BEHAVIORS ON ACCEPTABLE.
HIS UNWILLINGNESS TO PROVIDE
DOCUMENTS.
I SAID THIS A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
ON MARIA'S SUNDAY MORNING SHOW
ON FOX.
I SAID LOOK, ALL YOU HAVE TO DO,
IF YOU -- IF THERE IS NO FISA
ABUSE HERE, NO PROBLEMS WITH THE
FISA APPLICATION, IF THERE WERE
NO PROBLEMS, INFORMANTS WERE
SPIES OR WHATEVER WERE RUN INTO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN COME ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO IS SHOW THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ALL OF
THE DOCUMENTS.
LET THE INVESTIGATORS COMB
THROUGH THE DOCUMENTS.
WE ARE NOT GETTING MAD.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
WE WOULD EXONERATE THEM IN A
SECOND.
WHERE DOES THIS LEAD?
TOMORROW WE HAVE THE IG REPORT
COMING OUT.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
FIRST STEP FOR AMERICA AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI BEGIN THE HEALING PROCESS.
THE HEALING PROCESS WOULD BE
MADE MUCH EASIER IF WE COULD
COMPLETE THAT BY THEN DELIVERING
ALL OF THE DOCUMENTS TO US.
TOMORROW THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
DELIVER DOCUMENTS TO THE SPEAKER
AND MYSELF.
WE INFORMED EVERY REPUBLICAN
MEMBER ON OUR COMMITTEE, SIGNED
A LETTER TODAY TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO SAVE TOTALLY ON
ACCEPTABLE.
AN INVESTIGATION THAT WE
STARTED --
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU STOP IT?
>> TWO WAYS.
WE CAN HOLD MR. ROSENSTEIN AND
OTHERS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN CONTEMPT AND IMPEACH.
THE OTHER WAY WOULD BE FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO DEMAND THEM, TO ORDER THEM TO
GIVE US ALL THE DOCUMENTS.
THOSE ARE REALLY THE ONLY TWO
WAYS.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT NEEDS
TO HEAR THIS MESSAGE.
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO HEAR THIS
MESSAGE.
ARE YOU WILLING TO GO, SIR, AS
FAR AS IMPEACHING?
>> WELL I AM AM ALREADY PAST.
I WANTED TO MOVE TO CONTEMPT
MONTHS AGO.
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
BELIEVES HE CAN WORK WITH DOJ
AND WERE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
TRY TO WORK IT TOMORROW.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU MY PATIENCE
HAS RUN OUT.
I HAVE NONE LEFT.
NOW IT'S REALLY UP TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE HOUSE AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SUBPOENA GETS COMPLIED WITH.
>> Sean: WE CANNOT HAVE A
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES THAT IS PREVENTING
CONGRESS FROM DOING THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL JOB AND
THREATENING PEOPLE USING THE
POWER OF THAT OFFICE WHICH IS SO
POWERFUL TO INTIMIDATE, HARASS,